and the run-up to the unveiling ceremony
for its new RS Ford ruled out the red
carpet for the cars forbearers visitors
to the carmaker's facility in cologne
loved it the estimate for the first RS
was built in cologne says steel America
the car maker launched the 15th mrs and
the 17 mrs in nineteen sixty seven kilos
club is happy to have the chance to
present cars from the models history the
first of those two models featured a 55
kilowatt 1.7 liter engine with a paint
job sporting racing stripes but it was
body details in the 17 mrs that would
define the special models look its
standard v6 engine packs 66 kilowatts of
power but customers could also opt for a
racier 79 kilowatt version inside the
dash and dials emphasize the cars sporty
image
the s minus t lo says the first motors
were powerful but conventional later
ford introduced turbo engines fuel
injection and four-wheel drive special
rally racing technologies and ford
brought them to the street the brand
first brought out a street-legal rally
style car in the 1960s because of its
grill the escort RS was fondly known as
the dogbone the rs200 was an extreme
example of Ford's technology transfer
developed for Group B rally races it's
huge air intake scoops fed a mid-mounted
engine what rule changes force designers
to return to more conventional vehicles
the focus became a rally car but even
the street legal RS pulled a respectable
154 kilowatts out of four cylinders its
successor also a front-wheel drive
vehicle was a real eye catcher drivers
could call on its up to 500 newton
meters of torque when necessary hilux
buddies an amateur racer frank lloyd
time says this car still has its
original 5 cylinder motor and to handle
it you have to watch the rpms and torque
that means you can either torque it up
close to the red line or shift early and
pick up speed through torque when you
accelerate Ford started the countdown to
the official launch of the latest
generation RS with a surprise appearance
the prototype was piloted over the
carmaker's factory grounds by rally
racer and internet phenomenon ken Block
on the way to the presentation it was
his job to show off how well the car
handles even when pushed to the limit by
maneuvering past some expensive
obstacles
it was a final test for the new RS which
looks set to find a new fan base outside
the sport as well guests were impressed
the pro was too
well I mean I'm very happy that Ford has
developed you know the RS again brought
the Heritage back of the RS brand but on
top of that developing it with all-wheel
drive and more horsepower you know than
they have in the past is amazing so it's
been really cool to be a part of the
development process on such a very good
car the audience got a look at what the
new top-of-the-line focus can do but
only saw the final design after it had
been put through its paces that's when
Ford pulled off the wrapping paper on
the new compact made in cologne the look
is radical for the car maker
this designed us board design manager
enesta rupar says the focus RS was
developed here in Cologne but the
overall design was a joint effort with
the Ford Performance team in Detroit the
performance is everything in the compact
sports car segment cooling aerodynamics
and technology have to be top-notch the
models head engineer says its motor
which is the same as the Mustangs has a
2.3 liter EcoBoost it's been
fundamentally altered and adapted in the
RS it was implemented in conjunction
with the all-wheel drive of course he
says it's Tim Lloyd a lot systemic
necessarily under cruel that ladder
feature appears to have been made for
ken block's extreme driving style he's
glad Ford has implemented the change
so I've been pushing that for that for
years and Ford really listened and
listened to not only me though but the
the customers that the customers wanted
that too so really you know that initial
development of the all wheel driving the
idea that was something i was able to
help with and since then I've been able
to help with you know the testing and
tuning of the the all-wheel drive system
and the suspension so that's mainly what
I've been involved with in combination
with the carmaker's torque vectoring
technology the all-wheel-drive can
distribute up to seventy percent of the
engines 235 kilowatts of output to the
rear wheels and up to one hundred
percent of that to the outside wheel in
a curve so lateral acceleration of up to
1 g poses no problem hungry fans will
have to be patient though it's still
unclear exactly when the new RS will hit
the market